[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureux de vous
retrouver pour un nouveau numéro de
Parlement Hebdo l'émission qui revient
sur l'actualité de la semaine au
Parlement et notre invité François Noël
buffet bonjour vous êtes sénateur LR du
Rhône et président de la commission des
lois et au Sénat on va revoir avec vous
le film riche de la semaine et cette
semaine la réforme de retraite a donc
été adoptée après l'utilisation du 49-3
et après le rejet in extremis d'une
motion de censure du gouvernement à cet
épisode ouvre une crise politique pour
l'exécutif et la majorité présidentielle
malgré l'adoption du texte la
mobilisation sociale contre la réforme
des retraites se poursuit jeudi entre un
million et 3 millions de personnes ont
défilé par tout en France des
manifestations perturbées par des
violences et des casseurs dans ce climat
social tendu l'examen du projet de loi
immigration a été reporté il devait
pourtant être débattu à la semaine
prochaine au Sénat
le gouvernement a donc échappé de peu à
la censure à 9 mois après la réforme des
retraites et donc considérer comme
adopté elle est désormais devant le
Conseil constitutionnel mais les
oppositions n'ont pas dit leur dernier
mot le bras de fer se poursuit avec
l'exécutif tandis qu'Emmanuel Macron lui
reste droit dans ses bottes on en parle
mais je vous propose d'abord de revoir
la séquence qui a marqué l'Assemblée
nationale cette semaine Marco pommier la
majorité requise n'étant pas atteinte la
motion de censure n'est pas adoptée à
neuf fois prêt le gouvernement
d'Elizabeth borne est sauvé mais de
justesse
278 députés ont voté la censure dont 19
frondeurs à droite c'est plus que prévu
immédiatement l'opposition dénonce une
victoire à la Pyrrhus pour l'exécutif
mais qui peut croire que on va pouvoir
mettre la poussière sous le tapis encore
longtemps ce texte là de réforme des
retraites est profondément empoisonné
c'est pourquoi effectivement la solution
est la démission de la première ministre
le président de la Buick ne peut pas
faire autrement qu'à tout le mois
présenté aux Français un nouveau
gouvernement dans l'hémicycle le lundi
Charles de Courson défend la motion
transpartisane à l'initiative de son
groupe le député liotte dénonce un
passage en force du gouvernement sur la
réforme des retraites en réalité rien ne
vous obligeait ou 49-3 le courage le
respect des institutions le respect de
vos engagements aurait dit conduire au
vote ce vote vous l'auriez très
probablement perdu mais c'est la règle
en démocratie la majorité elle critique
une alliance baroque vous
direz en premier ministre avec Marine Le
Pen à Bercy avec Mathilde panot un
ministre de l'Intérieur la motion liotte
est rejetée même sort pour celle du
rassemblement national la réforme des
retraites est donc adoptée Mélanie Pesse
donne rendez-vous dans la rue pour une
censure populaire madame
la preuve violence verbale a débordé
dans la rue respecter le résultat des
urnes et les votes au Parlement
respecter nos solutions et respecter
enfin notre démocratie après son
adoption au Parlement la réforme des
retraites et désormais sur la table du
Conseil constitutionnel François Noël
buffet avec cette séquence et la
nouvelle mobilisation importante de ce
jeudi est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
si Emmanuel Macron est ou pas encore en
mesure de diriger correctement le pays
écoutez à ce stade je pense que la
réponse est oui la question est moins
la manière dont il va falloir trouver
des solutions pour sortir de cette
situation de crise car nous sommes dans
une situation de crise politique
parlementaire sociale parlementaire le
travail parlementaire a été fait les
débats ont eu lieu il y a eu du temps de
consacrer il y a eu beaucoup de choses
qui ont été faites 49 3 au final alors
qu'il y avait une autre voie possible
celle d'aller au vote et d'éventuelles
donc si c'était rejeté faire une
nouvelle lecture sur le choix du 49-3 il
relève pas du Parlement il relève de
l'exécutif qui a fait cette fois là il
pouvait y avoir le procédure aurait pu
continuer nous aurions nous organisation
à un autre débat à l'Assemblée puis un
autre Sénat puis enfin encore un autre à
l'Assemblée et auquel cas qui ont eu le
dernier hausse la règle et auquel cas
peut-être à ce moment-là simplement à
49-3 mai vous savez les plus belles
plaidoiries sont celles qu'on fait après
l'audience donc je ne sais pas ce qui
s'est passé ce qu'il y a certains c'est
que un climatisation qui est très très
fort
les manifestations ont été importantes
hier après les chiffres varient mais
plutôt tendance à croire celle du
mystère de l'Intérieur en tous les cas
quelques variantes près et être un peu
plus dubitatif sur les 3 millions de
mille personnes mais à la limite ce qui
est important qu'on choisit c'est qu'il
y a eu du monde c'est un manifesté et
d'ailleurs de ce point de vue là dans de
bonnes conditions ça c'était essentiel
et c'est très important
ce qui est beaucoup plus grave c'est
évidemment les violences la présence de
ces gens qui sont là pour cassés on y
reviendra le système parlementaire je
crois qu'il a en tous les cas pour ce
qui concerne le Sénat a fonctionné
il y a une responsabilité d'un certain
nombre de groupes politiques tout de
même quand vous avez à l'assemb national
je parle pas au Sénat parce que les
choses sont très différents
qui tient des propos d'une violence
d'une telle nature des comportements qui
sont
inacceptables dans un système
parlementaire respectueux respectueux à
la fois de leurs électeurs et à la fois
des institutions dans laquelle ils sont
élus ça crée aussi un climat de
absolument délétère et qui est même
dangereux pour le dispositif pour le
système mais c'est dangerosité espérons
qu'elle n'est pas une elle n'est pas non
plus un objectif politique qui
consistera déstabiliser le système
françois-elle buffet un mot quand même
sur le gouvernement il est passé à neuf
fois près de la censure et ce qu'il est
encore en capacité de diriger le pays et
ce qui est Isabelle bande doit partir
est-ce qu'il faut maniement
la censure a été évitée effectivement à
peu de voix près c'est ce qui démontre à
l'évidence qu'il y a
si ce n'est une fragilité en tous les
cas il peut y avoir une forme
d'inquiétude est-ce que Elisabeth borne
doit rester première ministrement doit
continuer une fois que je vais pas me
défausser si tu as l'initiative du
Président de la République mais on
attend en tous les cas de la part du
président de la République une prise de
hauteur suffisante avec des décisions
suffisamment fortes pour qu'elles soient
aussi le message de ce qu'il comprend et
de ce qu'il l'entend évidemment qu'une
position rigide à l'égard de ceux qui
organise le désordre est absolument
nécessaire en revanche sur le reste il
faut rester ouvert à la discussion et
prendre des mesures fortes peut-être que
ça passera le moment venu par une
évolution du gouvernement peut-être mais
ce n'est pas comprend bien que ça allait
pas de ma compétence mais il y a besoin
d'une mesure fort du président de la
République ça c'est certain mais est-ce
que ça peut passer aussi par un
élargissement de la majorité qui
permettrait de donner à
la majorité qui est toute relative les
voix qui lui manquent et notamment
est-ce qu'une alliance avec vous les
républicains et possibles moi j'ai une
position très claire là-dessus le
débauchage individuel est insupportable
et de toute façon il l'amène jamais rien
de plus
mais nous sommes une situation politique
extrêmement compliquée pris entre
l'extrême droite et l'extrême gauche
avec des gens qui se qualifient de
républicains et je crois que nous sommes
dans une difficulté réelle il faut dire
les choses telles qu'elles sont pas dans
une incarnons pas nous encore une
alternative crédible il faut dire les
choses aussi telles qu'elles sont et il
faudra construire cela est-ce que les
circonstances actuelles font qui
pourraient y avoir une plateforme un
accord type à l'Allemand qui soit clair
transparente j'allais dire
contractualiser sont remplies à
l'instant où je vous parle je ne le
crois pas en tous les cas pas maintenant
mais si cette situation devait advenir
elle ne peut se faire qu'à condition que
les choses soient parfaitement
transparentes de partis politiques à
parti politique sur je le redis sur un
exemple à l'allemande parce que le
risque serait autrement beaucoup trop
dangereux dangereux pour notre pays pour
nos institutions pour notre
fonctionnement politique risque de ce
fait d'amener au pouvoir des mouvements
d'extrême ce que nous ne voulons pas
naturellement
en tout cas la gauche et le
rassemblement national n'ont pas
terminée le combat contre la réforme des
retraites ils ont saisi le Conseil
constitutionnel dénonçant notamment la
procédure législative qui a été choisie
par le gouvernement en tant que
président de la commission des Lois du
Sénat est-ce que vous aussi vous avez
des doutes sur la constitutionnalité de
cette réforme des retraites je ne crois
pas sincèrement la procédure a été
parfaitement respectée on imagine bien
que avant même de l'engager les analyses
ont été faites donc je pense pas qu'il y
ait une difficulté sur la procédure qui
a été utilisée et je ne crois pas que le
Conseil constitutionnel maintenant il
est souverain est quelque chose à
reprocher de ce point de vue là sur les
débats ils ont eu lieu alors on peut
certains regrettent c'est noté le fait
que les débats étaient corsetés dans une
durée parfaitement contenue mais il
suffit de regarder des amendements qui
avaient été déposés par l'opposition
pour se rendre par l'opposition par les
opposants plus exactement qui étaient
amendements visant à simplement à gagner
du temps il y avait rien sur le fond
donc sincèrement je crois qu'à procédure
à respecter après il y a le jeu
politique qui est là mais le à respecter
j'ai pas d'inquiétude de ce point de vue
là a priori la gauche s'est lancée de
son côté dans l'organisation d'un RIP un
référendum d'initiative partagée elle
doit recueillir 4,9 millions de
signatures on n'y est pas mais est-ce
que au bout le Sénat laissera se réfère
un homme s'organiser si la procédure
aboutit hypothèse un texte doit être
déposé au Conseil constitutionnel le
Conseil constitutionnel doit constater
la régularité du texte ensuite lancez la
procédure si les 4 millions et demi de
personnes sont remplies alors là il y a
plusieurs hypothèses soit le Parlement
se ressaisit du texte et pourquoi pas
soit on va au bout de la procédure et le
référendum est organisé donc là encore
parce que nous sommes des démocrates il
faut laisser fonctionner la procédure
elle existe elle peut se dérouler et
puis on verra si le Sénat me menus veut
se ressaisir il y a toute petite
difficulté juridiques c'est que le rip
en général ne peut pas trop avoir lieu
lorsqu'il y a déjà une des assemblées
saisies par un texte il faut attendre
attendre moi un an voilà mais bon en
tous les cas si la procédure est engagée
et pour vous
ça peut être une sortie de crise
c'est une hypothèse mais je suis pas
certain que ce soit la meilleure
hypothèse je pense pour le coup pour une
réponse très politique qu'on a besoin
d'avoir de la part du plus instance de
l'État ou une prise de hauteur réelle et
qu'on redéfinisse on a besoin ce qu'est
le destin collectif des Français le fond
du fond il est quand même là parce que
les choses viennent de loin depuis
longtemps tout le monde constate cette
fracture de notre pays cette
communautarisation de la vie dans tous
les sens du terme et on a besoin de
réincarner un destin collectif et de se
reconnaître là-dedans tant qu'on n'aura
pas fait c'est agent de la mienne tour
n'y arrivera pas alors à cette crise
politique s'ajoute une crise sociale la
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites se poursuit voire même se
durcit dans ce contexte mercredi
Emmanuel Macron le président de la
République a donné une interview il est
resté ferme sur ses positions il a
dénoncé et bien les violences qui
émaillent certains cortèges de
manifestants ils souhaitent passer à la
suite de son quinquennat regardez les
réactions de plusieurs présidents de
groupe politique au Sénat
pas bien sûr qu'en disant que la foule
est moelle légitime que les élus bien
sûr je comprends le sens au fond et que
en infligeant à Monsieur berger le
patron d'un CFDT une sorte de aveu je
suis pas bien sûr que ça concourt à
l'apaisement vous voyez lucide courageux
combatif un président qui assume parce
qu'il prend un texte difficile à
entendre bien qui assume qui assume la
popularité qui dit je le fais parce que
c'est pour les générations futures c'est
pour l'avenir de ce pays je le fais au
détriment des critiques aujourd'hui je
trouvais que ce président était à la
fois Judit lucide courageux et combatif
arrogance suffisance condescendance et
irresponsabilité devant les Français moi
je suis sidéré parce que j'ai entendu
intérêt en pensant aux Français qui
aujourd'hui vont être pénalisés par un
président qui ne les comprend pas
buffet finalement est-ce que Emmanuel
Macron en restant inflexible mercredi
sur sa réforme des retraites et ce qu'il
n'a pas relancé la mobilisation contre
ce texte alors que je dis il y avait
entre 1 million et 3 millions de
personnes dans la rue souvent la forme
la plus importante que le fond et dans
les situations de crise comme celle-ci
mais presque tout le temps il faut
mesurer ces mots et ses paroles donc je
partage la vie de Bruno retaillod donc
l'enjeu maintenant c'est vraiment de
trouver les mots d'une part mais aussi
les actes qui vont permettre de sortir
de cette situation
on ne peut pas rester dans un climat de
crise aussi fort et par ailleurs utilisé
par des mouvements on en parlera sans
doute qui poursuivent un autre objectif
que leur retraite qui est la
déstabilisation de notre système
perdurer et moi je reste intimement
convaincu que une des pistes passera non
pas simplement par des moyens techniques
mais d'abord par une redéfinition de ce
que nous voulons pour notre pays de ce
que nous voulons pour les Français
tant que nous aurons pas dit aux
Français ce que l'on veut pour eux ou on
veut les emmener ensemble bien sûr qu'il
peut y avoir des difficultés je ne suis
pas naïf mais en tous les cas que chacun
se reconnaisse dans ce qu'un projet qui
soit un projet collectif on y arrivera
pas donc il y est urgent de reposer la
question fondamentale qu'est-ce qui fait
sens qu'est-ce qui fait notre nation où
veut-on aller ensemble et voulons-nous
tout s'aborder alors que nous avons un
des pays les plus beaux au monde en
attendant on a vu une hausse des
violences lors des toutes dernières
manifestations de ce jeudi le retour des
Black Blocs des casseurs des bâtiments
publics incendiés des policiers blessés
qu'est-ce qui se passe est-ce que le
pouvoir public la loi est toujours aussi
démuni face à ces casseurs qui
s'invitent dans les manifestations dans
les manifestations je rappelle qu'elles
sont déclarées une grande partie d'entre
elles d'ailleurs c'est dernier jour ne
l'était pas sur des points de
manifestation mais vous avez toujours
des mouvements extrémistes qui sont là
pour semer le trouble qui vient pas pour
le sujet de la manifestation mais qui
viennent pour le plaisir de casser de
vous ne pouvez avoir qu'une seule
réponse qui ne te réponse de fermeté
absolue c'est à dire que ces gens-là
doivent être arrêtés poursuivis
condamnés et impérativement mis de côté
ils savent vous n'avez pas l'autre choix
que de la fermeté à l'égard de ceci
j'entends bien je ne parle pas des
manifestants qui eux ont les syndicats
il faut d'ailleurs le redire ont plutôt
bien tenu leurs affaires ça s'est bien
passé ça a été parfaitement organisé
parfait impeccable mais ces voyous là il
y a pas une seule seconde de tolérance à
avoir à leur endroit il poursuivent non
seulement l'objectif de tuer et ça a été
dit de blesser nos policiers c'est une
chose donc nos concitoyens disons les
choses telles qu'elles sont aussi se
sont aussi nos concitoyens et de
déstabiliser le pays et de vouloir
renverser les institutions parce qu'ils
sont des gens d'extrême gauche vers le
ministre de l'Intérieur l'a dit
publiquement en disant même qu'il était
documenté sur le sujet ça c'est
inacceptable c'est la fermeté la plus
grande réponse ferme et ce qu'il faut de
nouveau outil législatif pour contrer
ces casseurs ou est-ce qu'on les a en
notre possession je pense quand il est
suffisamment équipé juridiquement
aujourd'hui pour les avoir je rappelle
qu'une époque le président du groupe
chez nous avait fait une proposition sur
les Black Bloc à plusieurs années ça a
été repris en partie ensuite donc on est
juridiquement équipé la réponse elle est
pas toujours juridique elle est pas
toujours de faire un texte de plus elle
est aussi politique elle est d'abord
politique
sur le feu avant de l'utilisation de
49-3 les violences
je vous dis parfois les mots sont plus
importants que le fond et quand on
dirige une institution quelle qu'elle
soit
l'enjeu c'est plutôt d'essayer de
d'apaiser que les choses se passent bien
sûr
un regard il faut sur nos concitoyens
parfois un regard bienveillant ce qu'il
n'a pas je sais pas moi je dis ce que
j'ai été maire pendant 20 ans les
municipal je suis élu au Sénat j'essaye
de ma conception de la politique c'est
que on essaye de faire fonctionner tout
le monde ensemble et l'honneur de la
politique c'est d'emmener tout le monde
ensemble c'est difficile tout le monde
sait que c'est difficile mais il y a
sûrement un chemin faut le trouver alors
pas de nouvelles lois sur les casseurs
est-ce que la doctrine du maintien de
l'ordre est la bonne est-ce qu'elle est
assez ferme ou est-ce qu'elle est trop
ferme alors que certains aussi dénoncent
les violences de quelques policiers
alors eux des manifestants pacifiques
alors attendez
il est toujours possible que dans des
mouvements aussi importants et puisse y
avoir un comportement ind manuel qui ne
soit pas acceptable les choses doivent
être traitées souvent là les doctrines
de la police tout le monde a salué
depuis maintenant plusieurs mois à une
singulièrement l'arrivée de leur nièce
et la préfecture de Paris la bonne
organisation des manifestations le
changement de doctrine et d'intervention
des services de police des repas
remettre en cause à chaque fois qu'une
manifestation les stratégies de temps
plus que je pense qu'elle fonctionne
plutôt bien donc il faut au contraire
soutenir nos forces de police
considérer que la doctrine nouvelle qui
était mise en place fonctionne mieux
qu'avant les circonstances également de
violences ne sont pas les mêmes ce qui
s'est passé il y a quelques années n'est
pas ce qui se passe aujourd'hui mais
néanmoins je pense que les forces de
police ne sont parfaitement adaptées et
donc c'est plutôt une bonne chose il
faut plutôt soutenir nos concitoyens
policiers pour l'instant on ne voit pas
de sortie de crise possible dire
maniement ni dissolution ni rien est-ce
que pour vous l'exécutif ne mise pas
tout simplement sur le pourrissement du
mouvement social
je crois que toute discussion puisse
redémarrer qu'on puisse retravailler
dans des conditions sereines il faut
déjà stopper ce climat de violence
première chose deuxième chose il faut
aussi que les partis politiques
singulièrement à l'Assemblée nationale
et pour ne pas les citer la nuit Pesse
de fonctionner de la manière dont il
fonctionne avec les propos de
provocation permanente de vulgarité
permanente et prennent conscience qu'ils
sont des députés de la nation et qu'ils
doivent de ce point de vue là respect au
mandat qui leur était confié et aux
institutions qu'ils servent et que l'on
retrouve ce climat apaisé car notre nous
ne trompons pas l'attitude des élus
quels qu'ils soient et bien elle est
regardée elle peut même être mi b et
quand on est violent avec un élu et
violent faut pas s'étonner ensuite
qu'une partie de la population d'ici un
élu le fait j'ai parfaitement le droit
de le faire donc là aussi il faut que ça
cesse alors dans ce climat social tendu
Emmanuel Macron a annoncé le report de
l'examen du projet de loi immigration
alors que ce texte devait être débattu
la semaine prochaine au Sénat que va
devenir à cette loi immigration elle les
explications de Cécile si xou
c'est le premier dommage collatéral de
la réforme des retraites le texte
immigration pas assez consensuelle pour
être voté au Parlement Emmanuel Macron
veut le reporter et le découper il y
aura bien une loi immigration il y en
aura sans doute il y aura plus sans
doute plusieurs textes immigration et
ils arriveront dans les prochaines
semaines initialement prévu en séance au
Sénat dès mardi se report a été demandé
par Gérard Larcher le président du Sénat
estime que les conditions ne sont pas
réunies pour débattre sereinement de ce
projet de loi après la séquence
parlementaire sur les retraites
dimanche soir avec le président de la
République la nécessité qu'un texte
aussi important
devait être examiné dans des conditions
apaisées
refuse en revanche un découpage du
projet cette méthode voulue par le
ministre de l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin
consisterait à séparer en trois textes
le projet actuel avec les mesures
consensuelles dans un texte du
Gouvernement et les dispositions plus
polémiques dont deux textes issus du
Parlement une méthode à la carte
dénoncée par Bruno retaillod le
président du groupe LR au Sénat réclame
une politique globale sur l'immigration
pour la loi de régularisation notamment
l'article 3 qui crée un titre de séjour
de régularisation sur les métiers en
tension là j'imagine qu'ils vont aller
rechercher l'appui de gauche à
l'Assemblée nationale et puis pour un
certain nombre de procédure un peu plus
contraignant la pluie à droite mais ça
peut pas marcher comme ça il n'y aura
pas notre soutien ni nous ni à
l'Assemblée nationale en réalité sur ce
genre de texte à la découpe même son de
cloche gauche le sénateur socialiste
Jean-Pierre Sueur ne suivra pas le
gouvernement s'il fait du découpage de
textes plutôt que de prendre une
nouvelle baigne et si je peux parler
comme ça après les retraites ils ont dit
il vaut mieux reculer ça je comprends
tout à fait mais croire qu'on va régler
cette question par des petits morceaux
de textes les uns après les autres qu'il
s'agisse de projets de loi ou de
proposition de loi inspirée etc non
conséquence de ce report il n'y aura pas
de séances publiques au Sénat la semaine
prochaine hormis les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
François manuel buffet d'abord un mot
sur le report de ce projet de loi
immigration je rappelle que vous êtes un
peu le spécialiste des questions
immigration au Sénat c'était la plus
prudent de reporter cet écran le
président du Sénat a bien fait de
demander au présent de retirer le texte
la question n'est pas d'aboutir c'est
une question de méthode l'idée n'est pas
de pousser les feux à tout prix sur un
texte quand le climat général est à
l'attention et que l'on sait que ce
texte est un texte qui va être clivant
naturellement je dis pas qu'il est pas
nécessaire il va être clivant donc on va
avoir des opinions qui vont s'opposer
donc
inutile de rajouter du conflit
supplémentaire ou de la tension
supplémentaire donc une bonne chose
qu'il était retiré alors retirez mais
tout de même Emmanuel Macron a une idée
il envisage de saucissonner ce projet de
loi immigration plusieurs textes qui
sera adopté par des majorités
différentes est-ce que pour vous c'est
cohérent alors de faire un tel
saucissonnage retirer pour des raisons
de circonstances ne veut pas dire qu'il
faut abandonner l'idée du projet je
pense qu'il faut naturellement le
remettre sur la table assez rapidement
le giféré que faire ce peu le plus
sereinement possible sur un sujet dont
nous avons besoin pour lequel nous avons
besoin de faire évoluer la loi c'est
absolument nécessaire et ça personne ne
peut dire le contraire et un besoin
d'évolution à partir de là je préfère
pour ceux qui me concerne un texte
unique pour quelle raison parce que je
crois que dans toutes les politiques
c'est un peu dans le complément de ce
que je disais il y a quelques instants
il faut avoir une vision cohérente du
système et de la politique que l'on veut
mener ceux qui manque à la France ceux
qui nous manque en ce domaine là c'est
d'afficher clairement quelle politique
migratoire nous voulons pour le pays et
pourquoi je dis ça parce qu'on a besoin
d'envoyer des messages évidemment à
l'étranger puis on a besoin aussi que
les Français comprennent ce que l'on
veut faire et à partir de là il faut
dire les choses très clairement donc ça
nécessite de la cohérence donc un seul
texte nous allons voir parce que
d'après ce que j'ai compris ce qui a été
dit d'ailleurs la première ministre doit
rencontrer le président du Sénat pour
mettre en place une nouvelle méthode de
travail je ne doute pas que le président
du Sénat aura les qualités convaincre la
première ministre de ce qu'il faut faire
mais nous avons besoin d'un texte
vraiment unique et qui se prennent dans
des conditions les plus sereines
possibles si nous y arrivons dans tous
les cas pas tout de suite alors les
députés les républicains proposent eux
aussi un nouveau texte une nouvelle
proposition de loi sur les migration il
ne vous ont pas concerté sur ce texte
bon j'ai lu ça effectivement alors non
j'ai pas été informé ni concerté j'ai pu
confesser que j'avais une proposition de
loi qui est prête depuis le mois
d'octobre que j'avais gardé dans mon
dossier la servi à amender le texte
actuel et celui de la commission qui
vient de sortir donc on va rester serein
là aussi et puis on va essayer de faire
les choses comme il faut pour que ça
avance sérieusement vraiment il est
absolument nécessaire que l'on est sur
ce sujet là qui est un sujet grave et
important la capacité de dire des choses
simplement et de pouvoir aboutir à des
mesures fortes vraiment nous en avons
besoin tout de même le président de la
République a fait une annonce importante
il a annoncé qu'il allait Ré former en
faisant moins de loi mais en prenant des
décrets pour modifier des règlements
est-ce que pour vous c'est une manière
de contourner le Parlement et bien je
vais lui proposer une solution chez le
fameux article 3 de la loi immigration
sur les métiers en tension il n'y a pas
besoin de loi
il suffit de retirer cet article et que
les préfets dans le cas de ce qu'on
appelle l'admission exceptionnelle au
séjour sur instruction du gouvernement
clair précise puisse eux-mêmes procéder
à ce type de régularisation dès lors que
les choses sont parfaitement claires et
transparentes une fois de plus et qu'on
s'assure qu'on a pas un appel
considérable c'est un premier exemple
qui fait que on n'a pas besoin de texte
vous êtes plutôt d'accord avec cette
méthode
[Musique]
d'une façon générale tout ce qui relève
du règlement doit être traité par
l'exécutif et le législatif doit
conserver l'essence même des choses
c'est une question de principe les lois
sont trop bavardes de toute façon et
contribuons mais si on peut arriver à
cette rigueur c'est une bonne chose on
va se quitter avec
on va se quitter avec un regard rapide
sur les temps forts la semaine prochaine
à l'agenda
[Musique]
et mardi prochain la commission
d'enquête du Sénat sur la pénurie de
médicaments va auditionner les
représentants des principaux
laboratoires pharmaceutiques et mercredi
les sénateurs auditionneront elle est
dirigeants des sociétés concessionnaires
d'autoroute sur leur super profit alors
que le gouvernement envisage de réduire
la durée de leur concessions et à
l'Assemblée les députés examinent un
texte symbolique mais fort une
proposition de résolution pour faire
reconnaître comme génocide la grande
famille qui a eu lieu en Ukraine de
1932-1933 orchestré par Staline et puis
rapport attendu celui de la mission
d'évaluation de la loi de 2016 sur la
fin de vie et c'est la fin de cette
émission merci beaucoup Merci à VOUS
buffet d'y avoir participé et merci à
vous de l'avoir suivi
[Musique]